qui en théorie essaient de faire ceci
sont contraints.
Mais peut-être il y a encore plus important,
nous avons déjà entendu parler du un pour cent,
du 99 pour cent.
Si l'état est pensé de cette façon plus stratégique,
en tant que l'un des acteurs principaux dans le mécanisme de création de valeur,
parce que c'est ce dont on est en train de parler, pas vrai ?
Qui sont les différents acteurs de la création de valeur
dans l'économie, et c'est le rôle de l'état;
a t-il été en quelque sorte rejeté comme étant un acteur secondaire ?
Si nous pouvions avoir une théorie plus large
de la création de valeur qui nous permette d'admettre
ce que l'état a fait et récolté quelque chose en retour,
ce pourrait être simplement que lors du prochain tour,
et j'espère que nous espérons tous que la prochaine grosse révolution
sera en fait écologique,
que cette période de croissance
ne sera pas seulement intelligente, menée par l'innovation,
pas seulement écologique, mais aussi plus ouverte,
de telle sorte que les écoles publiques dans les endroits comme la Silicon Valley
pourront aussi bénéficier de cette croissance,
parce que ce n'est pas le cas.
Merci
(Applaudissements)